do mad max because that's short
you were
i wasn't at the show when you guys did
mad max if you wanna it's okay we're all
gonna be here for everything that's not
yeah we can't play musical chairs all
the time
[Music]
hey conan o'brien here with another
edition of behind the nonsense
where uh we go behind the scenes
of some of the uh bits that we've really
enjoyed over the years we talk about
them and maybe we hear some of uh what
went into creating the madness i'm
sitting here with not all the writers
just the ones that had nothing better to
do
we're going to be talking first
about the cold open we did at comic-con
a number of years ago
when mad max fury road was all the rage
we went down to san diego our cold open
was a tribute
to the aesthetic
of
mad max fury road and so maybe we should
just show it and then talk about it
sounds good let's do it
[Music]
god i look good
oh oh hey andy hey conan i'm heading
down to san diego to comic-con now are
you ready sure you're gonna take the
train no you know it's only a little
over two hours so i thought i'd drive
you know listen to some tunes on the way
down driving sounds fun can i take along
of course
now yeah
let's go to copy let's do it
[Applause]
like merit i'm hitting the drone
i don't know where we got lost i still
can't see it i'm coming down
see we passed san clemente yeah we're
off to five we passed saint clemente
we should have hit la jolla by now you
know well the thing is is the guitar's
so loud i can't hear the gps i'm sorry
it's so much fun i get carried away i
know i know but it's okay hit me up
before we go oh here we go here we go
[Music]
yeah that was a great idea i had nothing
to do with it how was that hatched levi
you came up with that i came up with it
during a walk with jose where we had
walked by a few year old billboard and i
had just seen and we were talking about
different ways and it went through a few
incarnations i think incorporating the
cars and maybe having i remember at one
point we were maybe gonna have you
strapped to the front of it the way that
tom hardy is in the movie so we went
through that and then once the doof
warrior thing came in
with you and then once our special
effects team jumped on and we're like oh
we can we will make a real flamethrower
guitar first of all i like it when the
parody fits what needs to happen for the
cold open the idea that andy and i just
need to get from la to san diego where
comic-con is
and well let's let's drive down i i
think uh the directing here the shot
selection is so incredible that shot
where you move up and you see our band
and they're banging away i mean we're
mimicking what happens in the movie but
we're doing it with our band and they're
still wearing their fedoras and
they're not really wearing uh
post-apocalyptic desert wear and then
that you swing around and you see andy
and then you see me and it's just
beautiful tracking shots there's so much
we do that's uh
that's improvised and silly and remotes
things that are played really loose and
then this was just all about precision
we shot it all in one day and there's so
many moving parts uh we drove out to
lancaster eric allard our special
effects wizard at the time just you know
had a ton of like pyrotechnics that you
had to deal with and fast moving cars
and so i shot it with one of those dolly
trucks and seth who's behind right now
was uh doing a whole remote control
thing with this special dolly truck that
they rented that had a camera on an arm
which we'd of course never worked with
it was such a movie set you can jump out
for a second seth can't you or you're
still busy shooting this
yeah we should we've strapped seth into
the side of man come on in here and take
a bow seth seth
it just to me uh if you're gonna do
parody the the shots have to be just
right and if i'm not mistaken there's
also a way that it looks like the the
color saturation
is messed with we tweaked all the levels
yeah you each other level so it's got
that same
answer to everything that's true
every time i ask you anything you say we
tweaked all the levels and i'm like oh
good and then that was also robash with
seth working on the colors because when
it first opens the sky has that kind of
post-apocalyptic look which the original
shot of course didn't and that was you
and rob ash our head editor just
changed the whole world of those shows
gave it a dusty feel and yeah you know
it's a nice palette yeah it's got a lot
of it feels like the grays and set the
stage i mean you're you're playing this
at comic-con so you guys
had to pay attention all this detail
because you're playing it in front of
1500 die-hard movie fans well actually
yes at comic-con exactly and it's the
spread this is from black spreckels
theater which is huge and beautiful and
packed and i'm backstage first time yeah
and i was so excited to be backstage
because i knew
when we have something all loaded up and
ready to go and we know we've got it the
crowd is there and they're really
excited and we dip to black and we wait
a second and then we come up and we know
we've got it
that was sweet the rest of the show was
absolute [ __ ]
great opener it was a real challenge
because we shot at all single camera
yeah and i mean we had a huge day we i
mean basically we're there at sunrise
and then didn't leave until sundown
didn't it take like three years to shoot
fury road and seth could have shot it in
12 days
yeah hey message to hollywood uh
whatever you're doing is wrong get seth
the whole thing 10 pages a day without
you yeah get seth and just shoot 10
pages a day and it's going to look that
good and uh you've got it all you've got
you know you're you're fools i'm selling
your fools right now that whole thing
came in under five grand
it is apparently the most expensive it's
the most expensive thing we've ever done
our
it was one of the first things i had
worked on because i was new to the show
one of the most expensive things we've
ever done i think so yeah easily i think
you know us this is the hot dog we
actually missed their profit predictions
because yeah
we got to think of what's the piece we
spent the most money on for the least
return in terms of laos i'll come up
with that i'll find it or the writer you
spent the most money on they gave you
the list
[Music]
and the search is over
yeah
these things are supposed to be loose
and
casual happened to be in the
neighborhood and dropped bob
[Laughter]
we all assumed we'd add the flames to
that guitar in post which we do all the
time
and we went back to look at the truck
and he was testing out the guitar that
was shooting planes we're in southern
california right which is constantly
plagued by drought
they handcuff you here if you've got
matches from a restaurant in your pocket
and eric allard built a real
flame-throwing guitar now forest fires
aren't a big problem in the australian
outback uh after the apocalypse but um
this is a different situation and as you
can see in that i had to ride down the
road and there were telephone poles on
either side of me and i was with
electrical wires and i was shooting it
and i remember people saying um just
remember whenever we come up to a
telephone pole try and cut it
cut the flames
try
hey comedian with no experience and very
little uh three-dimensional coordination
when you see the uh telephone poles come
up try and stop it because if you light
one of those on fire we'll knock out the
power first
for all of lancaster which would be a
tragedy
did we get the hot dogs in post we added
those those flames were fake the hot
dogs were real oh the hot dogs were real
i was hoping they were fake because the
fact that we built the flamethrower but
added the hot dog
yeah we had a real flamethrower but the
fake flames for the hot dog cost seven
hundred thousand dollars on to la jolla
on the fury road take me up fellas all
right here we go